[Music]
my name is guy Rangel I'm CTO and
co-founder of coke Knights with me I
have a quarter page and we're going to
talk about how cognate is using google
cloud technologies to enable machine
learning on industrial data and in
particular we'll talk about time series
data and BigTable as two of the key
technologies and problems that we are
solving so a little bit about ignites
we're a young company less than two
years old just crossed a hundred
employees we're working with asset
intensive industries so basically means
large industrial companies that have big
machinery that costs lots of money a lot
in the oil and gas vertical also in
shipping and our mission is to liberate
industrial data from silos and piece
that data together to form a model of
industrial reality so that humans and
machines can make better decisions and
take better actions so it's a model
that's real time and historic so you
have both the present state what's going
on and it's it has all the previous data
too which is important if you want to
try to predict the future so what
exactly is a an industrial reality model
or I'll try to to show a little bit
it depends on how you view it
there are many angles to kind of look at
this model
this is a typical operator view so if
you're in a control room in an
industrial plant this is very close to
what you typically see this is data now
streaming in live from the North Sea
that's about one to two seconds delay it
is data that it is concerning a single
tank outside on a oil platform or inside
actually the tank is called 20 V a zero
zero two and a typical oil platform will
contain anywhere from ten thousand to a
hundred thousand sensors climb series
like this so here you have a handful but
it it's just a tiny piece of a huge
machinery so this is the kind of
real-time what's happening right now you
also want to see as an analyst what has
happened in the past each one of these
squiggly lines represents about one
gigabyte of data this is one year of
data I really like this chart it's my
new hobby to play with it it's kind of
like Google Earth that you zoom in and
like view the data at any resolution and
you know given that this is about ten
gigabytes of data you've probably
noticed by now that the next Wi-Fi
doesn't support downloading all that
data this fast so you need a back-end
that can quickly crunch the data and
give you the data at the resolution that
you want and you can go all the way down
here to the to the rural data points
which will pop up when you zoom in
enough
and of course you can view this in
different ways so this is a view that
humans tend to like it's a
three-dimensional view we imported the
entire cad model of the oil platform we
connected it with all the other data so
for instance if we want to see the tank
that we just viewed data from which is
aptly named twenty VA zero zero two you
can see exactly where that is and what
it looks like and what it's connected to
you know browsed the data in three
dimensions so this just to give you a
little impression of what we mean by
industrial reality model I want this
model to be up-to-date and contain the
data today and for what happened in the
past by the way the the charting library
that I just showed you we couldn't find
that so we had to make it and we open
sourced it so if you're interested yeah
you can use that it's not tightly
coupled to the cogniser back-end so if
you you know have any kind of provider
that can give you data at different
resolutions you can use that uses
reactant d3 so the scale of data to be
ingested is huge and it's growing very
fast if you look cognate handles lots of
different data types to build it the
model of industrial reality so that can
be a RP data it can be maintenance logs
it can be 3d models like you saw but if
you look at the data by volume
ninety-nine point seven percent of the
data that we have is time series data
that's really where the the huge data is
even though the 3d model was large it's
about ten gigabytes that the time series
data dwarfs that and it's exploding and
all of that times there's data I need to
go somewhere it needs to be stored and
to be processed it need it needs to be
queryable so how do we do that what was
what is under the hood so when we
started out building cognates we started
with a few principles and one of them is
impact on it it kind of seems strange to
say this but you have to kind of write
it down to it for it to matter but I
it's easy as a technologist to to build
technology for technology's sake for
because it's cool and I've been guilty
of that in the past we've been lucky to
have large customers demanding customers
very early on to guide us in finding out
what the real use cases are that create
real value then it speeds we want to
show something as fast as possible so
you can iterate you can get feedback and
those two put together the kind of
there's a consequence to that and that
is that you want to use managed services
wherever you can especially for anything
that is stateful because handling you
know a stateful storage service that has
to scale up and down that has to you
know have backups have redundancy have
all that logs for who access the data
etc all of that stuff is just painful to
implement and it's gonna slow you down
and it's not something that yeah so we
recognized very early that we needed
time series database and our hypothesis
was that we could get this as a managed
service to that there would be something
that out of the box as an API supported
this and our requirements were that it
would be robust and durable so it means
that we don't drop data no data point
should be dropped it will have to
support a huge volume of reads and
writes rights in particular and you
always get new data in
low latency so that you can show the
real-time version of what's going on you
want to see data at any time scale so
you want to zoom that view and it is
zoomed in view that I showed you you
want to be able to efficiently backfill
so if you're onboarding a new customer
and that customer has a million data
points per second being generated and
you can handle to millions then
backfilling it's gonna take a long time
if they have a year of data for you to
backfill it's gonna take another year
before you're done with that because you
can spend 1 million of your capacity on
the new data and then 1 million per
second will be old and you want to be
able to efficiently map over data in in
order so the sequential reads for
training Mobile's for instance so we
experimented with the open ts to be at
the beginning it's a great piece of
software and the cool thing is you can
use BigTable which is a managed storage
back-end so you can use open TS to me
with BigTable as the backend which is
very nice but it had a few shortcomings
so for instance it's not durable that
means if if you send a piece of data to
it the data points it will acknowledge
that you got the data point before it's
written which means you can actually
lose data if you're scaling it up and
down and it instantly used the front
fill path for for batch backfields which
made backfilling very inefficient and
there were a few other things as well so
we chose to build our own time series
logic on top of BigTable so BigTable is
a fully managed service which as you
know we really wanted it supports a huge
number of reads and writes per node it's
been tried and tested on very large
user-facing distributed systems at
Google and it has this property which
most time series databases don't our
know most key value stores don't have
which is that you can scan forward
efficiently the the keys are stored in
order a lot of key value stores will
hash the keys so that you get the load
distributed evenly but BigTable doesn't
do that that means you don't have to
jump around when you're reading
sequential data it also means that so
the flip side of that is that you can
run into situations where you get hot
spotting so you need to write your code
around that but for us it's a it's a
price that's it's been worth it for us
so I'll hand it over to Carter page here
who is a senior engineering manager for
cloud the table Thanks gear so I'll talk
a little bit about I'll talk a little
bit about clapping table how to get a
fit for IOT and why are we seeing more
customers coming to it I do want to say
like I'm I'm particularly excited to be
presenting with cognate I think that the
stuff that they're doing is really neat
I think his point about doing impactful
things doing a comprehensive story of
IOT is very exciting the idea of not
just connecting that other devices and
getting the data but once you've got
literally tens of thousand devices way
more than a single human could actually
monitor thinking about how do you
extract data react to that and manage
you know very high risk asset situations
and he's going to get into some really
cool stuff after this but let me talk a
little bit about cloud big table and how
that is a good fit for these types of
use cases a quick show of hands just to
get a sense of the audience who's
familiar with distributed databases like
Cassandra HBase things like that okay
all right so this is not going to be
rocket science to most people
the main thing you know particularly for
large IOT use cases where people are
looking at collecting massive amounts of
metrics is being able to handle this
really large-scale traffic so a couple
years ago for example we did a load test
with a company where we process the
entire US trade basically simulated the
entire US trade markets all being
processed together which we process like
25 billion records in about an hour and
that's capable just due to this scale of
cod BigTable and how it works we were
peaking at about 34 gigabytes per second
and about 34 million operations per
second on BigTable on a single instance
and the reason this works is because
BigTable was built for very very high
scalability and you essentially get
linear characteristics way out on the
curve so BigTable was initially designed
by Google as a backing store for our
crawler and so it was stored to keep a
copy of the worldwide web it's been used
its expanded internally it's been used
for a lot of other products as well and
so we've put about 14 years of
engineering into keeping keep finding
new upper limits and breaking those so
every distributed system eventually you
have this you have this straight line
that goes out and a Mitchell it flattens
out everything eventually hits a
bottleneck or you might hit something
where just you know if you've got an
HBase cluster with a thousand machines
you're just going to hit probabilistic
machine failures and there's an overhead
for your operations and things like that
so we will eventually flatten out but
pretty far out and we would take a lot
of work for you to get up to the kind of
scale where you would notice the reason
this is important linear scaling from a
business perspective is this gives you
predictable cost of revenue so when
you're thinking about building a system
and you're like I've got a terabyte of
data and now this has to go to ten
terabytes petabytes usually if you're
building this on top of your own kind of
home managed Cassandra system you're
gonna have to rethink
each time you hit one of these new tears
alright now how am I going to deal with
this I've got a lot more machines I'm
gonna need a new on-call rotation I'm
gonna need new strategies to be able to
deal with this here it's just a matter
of you know cranking up your nodes and
the number of nodes you need is
proportional to the throughput that you
need so give a quick overview for how
cloud bigtable works you have clients
that basically talk to a single front
end point that load balances to the
nodes so you don't need to think about
address mapping or talking to individual
nodes themselves I'll take that layer
away and talk a little bit about what's
going on in eat the covers so the data
itself is being stored durably in a
underlying file system called Colossus
and the BigTable servers themselves are
actually not storing any data they are
taking the responsibility for serving
the data and every row is assigned to
only one node so the entire key space is
basically balanced across these
different nodes and this allows a
similar one to be by being responsible
for Anna vigil row allows for add misty
of operations on it allows for read your
own rights the underlying the advantage
here of having the file system and the
data dissociated is allows us to do some
some clever things in terms of being
able to rebalance workloads very
aggressively so you may have a customer
that has changed their underlying
workload which then impacts how are
using BigTable or you may have diurnal
patterns you may have different things
that are coming on and going going off
during the middle of the day changes
which tablet servers or nodes are
getting more or less activity and what
we'll do is we'll actually identify
these changes in patterns and we will
just reassign BigTable resign areas of
data to different notes and so this
allows a couple of things one is allows
you not have to not have to worry too
much about per node hot spotting you can
hotspot individual rows which is which
is a problem but in terms of getting
unlucky and having one server that's
hotter than the rest we'll balance that
out it also means higher utilization
and by having higher utilization these
knows by by keeping things balanced
you're not having a provision for the
hottest note or trying to keep all the
notes fairly well balanced and that
actually means cheaper service relative
to running this on a HBase cluster
Cassandra cluster in addition to
rebalancing you can resize up and down
fairly trivially we have some customers
who might have ingestion workloads which
only need a few nodes and they might run
a batch at the end of the month through
the end of the week and they might want
to scan a scale but up to say 300 notes
and you can do that fairly
instantaneously
they'll take maybe you know if you've
got a really large data set may take 10
to 20 minutes for the data to rebalance
or the nodes just added but it can be a
good way to to make those batch jobs you
run once a week run really fast when
you're done you scale it back down again
the basic data model it's kind of like a
a it's key value but has more dimensions
to it so you have a single index which
is Euro key and then your data is stored
in columns and the columns are a tuple
of basically a column qualifier and a
column family the column family is
defined in your schema and the column
qualifier is defined at insertion time
the table is sparse so any you know
column family calling qualifier tuples
that you don't fill in for a given row
don't cost against your actual space the
database is also three dimensional so
under each of those cells is an
arbitrary number of versions so you can
either you can you can keep them there
you know pretty much indefinitely as
long as your row key doesn't get beyond
a couple of hundred Meg's or you can
instill garbage collection say alright I
want you to wipe out any data that's
over a week or is you know just keep the
last five versions or something like
that
Wednesday yesterday we announced that we
have replication now so between two big
tables in a region we will replicate the
data between them this has a few
advantages the first is it
your failure domain so you're no longer
living to the failure domain of a single
zone you've got two zones of the failure
domains that gives you a higher
availability and another advantage that
people use particularly because the the
replication is asynchronous is a
workload isolation so some customers may
have their critical low latency serve
loads on one cluster and then maybe
doing batch reloads in another and they
by doing it on the other one they're not
interfering with each other essentially
the effective result of this on the high
availability size would get an extra
nine unto our SLA if you're using the we
have a we have a have a high
availability application policy I won't
totally get into those right now but you
can go read up on these you have
application policies that can define how
you want your traffic to be routed and
if you use the high availability one
you'll get automatic zero-touch failover
so if there's any problems until the
night you don't have to get paged
it'll just failover for you being a
large data tool and you know a database
that's designed for terabytes petabytes
actually we need really powerful tools
to be able to make them the most
advantage of your database and so we've
got deep integrations with bigquery with
data proc dataflow bigquery the queries
are not as fast as if you're going
against native bigquery because big
query is an offline store and there's
certain optimizations a bigquery to be
online be able to get single-digit
milliseconds latency which makes the
bigquery queries on a little slower but
it's nice because you can do ad hoc
queries in your data without having to
write a MapReduce job if you do want to
write a MapReduce job you can use Cloud
Data proc or you can use our internal
replacement for MapReduce which is
housed inside a data flow and then also
this week we're announcing that we have
a deep first-order integration with
tensor flow which just got put on to get
out and so people can start playing
around with that so I'll hand it back to
gear here thank you
so with that background I'll go into a
little bit of detail on how cognate is
using a cloud BigTable to store its data
and then we'll move on into machine
learning and eventually you'll see what
I wouldn't no can do so Carter talked
about the data model of BigTable this is
our basic data schema so the first thing
that is very important is how you choose
your row keys because that's the only
thing that you can kind of look up right
and fast
so our row keys consists of a sensor ID
plus a timestamp or a time bucket that
means that you can look up very fast the
values for a particular sensor at a
particular point in time and you can
also then scan through all the values of
a sensor in order which is nice if you
want to train a mobile and that's a very
inexpensive operation inside of each row
we store more than one value it's not
just one value per row we we stuff a lot
of time data points inside each row
typically around a thousand data points
per row so you have the timestamps which
are just unique times timestamps and
then you have values which are floating
points and of course it's binary stuff
it's just drawn out in readable numbers
here but it's all binary to save space
and actually a big table that's
compression for you too so what you'll
see if you if you if you stop ingesting
new data into your big table instance
you'll see that the total size of it
goes down which can be scary at first if
you don't know what's going on where's
my data going but it's actually a good
thing
here's how we architected our data
ingestion pipeline so every step along
this path is auto scaling the Carter
talked about how easy it is to scale
BigTable and we have a service which
looks at the lobe and then scales it up
and down it's a it's pretty simple logic
so it starts with cloud load balancing
and then an API node which is a
kubernetes service which has this
authentication and authorization then it
will put the data point on to a pub sub
Q and then it will say to the client we
got your data we're not gonna lose it so
pub sub is another component that we use
a lot it's a very nice component in the
way that it scales to whatever you ask
for if you look at the documentation for
pub sub we will say like the limit on
the number of publisher pre-operation
unlimited and subscribe operations
unlimited so it's kind of that's kind of
bold statement we haven't run into the
limit there once it's on the queue it
gets picked up by a subscriber to that
queue which will package the data and
write it to BigTable so that's where our
time series writing logic lives and once
it's been written there's a new job put
on a queue to compute aggregates so
those are roll-ups that we use to be
able to to answer queries about any
arbitrary time scale and efficiently
that's what we need in order to do the
dynamic zooming that that you saw at the
beginning your KP is our throughput and
latency for this kind of pipeline it's
typically able to you you look at and we
get so the data that comes in is
queryable after 200 milliseconds in the
99th percentile and we regularly have
little million data points per second
and I'm pretty sure it could do
much more than that - yeah and querying
much simpler this is some kind of
synchronous operation so it goes to the
API in old and then straight to BigTable
one of the optimizations that you want
to do if you want to transfer a lot of
data here is that typically API
developers like to have JSON data and
for most applications like dashboards
that makes sense if you're writing a
spark connector to your API and you want
to run machine learning on that and
transfer lots of data then the Jason
serialization and deserialization
becomes an issue so you want is
something like Portugal buffer another
binary protocol for that and it's not
really the size that matters because if
you gzip to Jason it's very small anyway
because it's very repetitive but it's
it's the memory overhead of doing that
serialization so that's a that's a nice
optimization I want to talk a little bit
about cleaning of industrial data
because it's something that's often
overlooked and if you want to make a
useful application in the industrial IOT
space it's not enough to have time
series in AI a lot of people are running
around saying time series plus AI is
gonna solve everything but a like a very
simple question is if you have a hundred
thousand time series coming from an oil
rig and you want to make a predictive
model for this one tank that we saw
which time series will you pick how do
you pick those you're gonna manually go
over all the diagrams it's gonna take
you a lot of time so typically we see
these data science projects and they
they're really about finding the right
data so that's about 80% of the time
they spent on and then you know at the
end of the project you have a wrap up
where you try to model something if you
want to
truly understand what's going on in the
industrial world you need to be able to
get data from a lot of sources data like
the metadata of the time series the
equipment information like who made it
when was it replaced the failure logs
from previously work orders 3d models
and the process information like how
things are physically connected and
logically connected which component is
upstream of this and it's not enough to
have all this data in one place it needs
to be connected the hard part is
connecting it and the glue that holds
this together is the the the object in
the physical world and the unfortunate
thing is that the same physical object
has a different name depending on what
system you ask so we spent a lot of time
on this contact realization like
figuring out how we map the IDs from one
system to a unique ID for each asset for
each physical object so if you look at
the cleaning pipeline here there's a
this thing called an asset matter which
we spend a lot of time developing and
which will assist expert and do
automatic mapping in many cases of IDs
from one system to another to be able to
make this connected contextualized model
so I'm not gonna
you're probably wondering now what this
windmill does and why it's here so I'm
just gonna say a little bit more and
then I'll get to it predictive
maintenance you've probably all heard
about this there is a great business
case for predictive maintenance we have
seen cases where a single equipment
failure on a piece of subsea equipment
costs a hundred million dollars to fix
so obviously you want to prevent that
right
but this is also why it is so hard to do
because the failures are fairly rare
there is not a lot of labeled data
[Music]
imagine what we would cost to get enough
label data to kind of validate your
mobile let alone train it so you
typically start with these unsupervised
approaches and for anomaly detection
what we've seen is there's between two
classes of approaches for how to do this
one is forecasting based so means that
you will take a set of sensors you'll
hide one of the values and you try to
predict it using the others and if your
prediction is far from what is the
actual value then you flag that as an
anomaly the other approaches you take
you take your sensor data your set of
sensors you plot them in a n-dimensional
space and you see what what points are
close to each other they form clusters
and those clusters typically represent
different operational states so you'll
have a cluster around the running state
you'll have a cluster around the idle
state you have a clustering stick
powering up powering down maintenance
and if you have new points and it
doesn't fit it's far from any of these
cluster centers then that is an anomaly
now let's let's look at this live so
this demo is as live as it gets it has a
lot of moving parts literally so there's
no everything that you see here is live
there's no pre trained model there is no
there is no
pre-generated data the data is going to
be created right here right now and
we'll train the model and we'll see if
it works so are you excited okay so
let's see if we we get data from this
wind turbine now and it looks like we do
this is a different view of the wind
turbine it's kind of a 3d view into
what's going on here
that's the sensor values I can turn this
knob I can increase the speed you'll see
it will start to produce more energy
it's a it's producing a lot of energy
for a wind turbine this small so let's
let's go into drew Jupiter I'm sure
those of you are working with data are
kind of familiar with this so we're
going to interact with the cold night
API we are Python SDK which is also open
source so first we're gonna just log in
here we're gonna select the write data
and then we're gonna plot it this live
plotter
will show kind of the analyst view of
this you see if I adjust the speeds this
it'll go down
if I pick it up it's gonna go up a bit
and this what you see on the screen is
going to be our training data so I'm
gonna give it a little bit more time so
it's seen a little bit of normal
operation of this wind turbine we
brought this we painfully brought this
wind turbine for you here it's 3d
printed looks very homemade we got it
through airport security we were I was
taken aside by security here at Google
next they were they were wondering what
this kind of base is because this wind
turbine thing isn't mounted on it and as
wires coming out of it and it has this
like red scary light on it
so I've done a lot of explaining to
bring this here now I need to stop this
plotting to move on I'll create an
anomaly detector for this and I'll
select a time range for it now this is
pushing the training operation up into
the clouds so it doesn't actually happen
on my computer the SDK will just do an
API call to train the model and then we
get the job ID and we can vary for the
state of that job it's not a lot of data
right now so it took very little time to
train and now we can create another
plotter and it's gonna plot again live
data from this wind turbine but this
time it's also going to plot the output
of the predictor normally detector so
how can we introduce an anomaly here
well I'm gonna use brute force I'm going
to hold it back here
it takes a little bit of time for the
data to appear in this Python thing and
now you'll see it's detected an anomaly
you see their red background there and
it should go back to normal again once
I've let it you there there you have
live anomaly detection yeah now it's
back to normal so operators can use this
to monitor you know if you want to
monitor a hundred thousand time series
you can't do that manually you can't put
it up on the screen and people watch it
well now operators can be alerted to you
know strange conditions I think you can
kind of look into what's going on and
hopefully prevent the next 100 million
dollar failure before it happens
so another very useful thing that we do
like once you've detected this anomaly
your first question is going to be
something like has this happened before
or has something similar happens so we
implemented something called similarity
search in the API which is not really
machine learning but it is a very useful
thing and it is very computationally
expensive to do so you can take a time
period of a set of sensor and look for
that pattern in a different set of
sensors or in the same and find the
similar portions
so this this this talk also has all two
ml in the title and there's a bit okay
so auto ammo on oil rigs you have
hydrocarbons and if there is a leak and
you have a spark then it's potentially
very dangerous so they're very they're
very they're always looking to see if
there are faulty wires faulty wires can
be very dangerous and so typically what
they do is they have these regular
expect inspections every six months or
every year where they go over everything
but these damaged wires they they don't
appear over time there they're typically
the result of someone stepping on
something or you know some something
mechanical happened at a particular time
point in time so what we try to do is
build a model which can detect faulty
wires so that you can wear a camera on a
helmet or you CCTV or other ways of
gathering images and come in the
background always look for this kind of
failure I'm not trying to replace those
inspections we are trying to augment
them and make it even better so we
trained the model using tensorflow to
detect faulty wires and also tell us
where in the image the failure is this
is a project that we spent three months
on and we were able to get to particular
accuracy and then that was about ninety
five point five percent on precision and
recall and then in June we got access to
auto ml so we figured would upload the
data set there and see how well that
would do so
what that looks like so training a model
with all two ml is just if you if you
can upload a bunch of images onto a web
page and you can edit a CSV file then
you can do it so we did that and in five
minutes I was able to get model with
96.1 and 96 point to some precision and
recall so that was half a percentage
points up and then but then we we didn't
give up we tweaked our own wobble a
little bit more so we were able to get
that one even higher so we were able to
get to 95 percent precision and 99
percent recall on our own model which
it's kind of it's better on one metric
but not the other so it's still but the
big difference I think is that we spent
three months doing it and it took five
minutes to train they're all 2 ml
let's see what what that can do on my
way here on the first day at Moscone I
found this wire outside and it looked
dangerous so I yeah so now I run the
ultramel on it and it was not part of
the training sets this is kind of a new
hobby for me to kind of go around and
look for faulty wires but yeah it really
caught that quite well and on my way to
the rehearsal which I did back in June I
also found this full-day traffic light
wire this is kind of a knob that you
push to make that pedestrian light go
green and it also catches that really
well so so I think it is possible to do
to do this and I think there is a class
of problems that you can solve in
industry like rust and leaks and kind of
using using camera feeds as a sensor
that can be very powerful and it's
rememba Lin getting people out of harm's
way
yes so I'll hand it over to Carter to
wrap it up Thanks gear if we have any
time yeah we'll have a couple time for
four questions after this I'm sure
Europe will build it join us yeah so
quick review again the cognate basically
built the system on top of GCP focusing
on the scalability and the throughput of
cloud BigTable and focusing on the
capabilities of auto ml he was able to
take a a training exercise which took
three months with tensor flow I was able
to do it in five minutes with Auto ml
which is really exciting for companies
that want to tap into this type of
technology without having to hire an
army of data scientists that everyone
can hire a gear and they're in their
company so also one of the things
actually I don't know if it was clear
when things were switching around when
he did the the windmill was was the you
saw some code but he didn't actually
program the the training model for that
he just highlighted the part that he had
done before and said this is bad and so
they were able to put this out in the
field they don't need to have in
programmers they can have engineers who
know what looks that on the graph
highlight that and then expand it out to
tens of thousands of metrics and be able
to to quickly identify things that are
going going wrong and that's really
exciting to be able to scale these
things out to to industry we have
replication now in cloud BigTable which
is going to provide higher availability
and some great features around workload
isolation and it provides a great basis
for large-scale data analysis and
machine learning if you want to learn
more about the technologies you saw here
here's a handful of links there is the
cloud BigTable main product page at
cloud google.com slash BigTable there's
a bunch of material underneath that and
then we also have the various machine
learning pages up there so you can learn
about machine learning in general under
the products page and
there's a master page for auto ml and
then at the bottom there is the
tensorflow integration with BigTable
that we launched this week and so that's
all we have
[Music]